come on sir the math thing isn't the
problem night shift's keeping you and
kevin apart
you two just need a bone what did you
say don't say it again
i said you two need a bone how
dare you detective diaz i am your
superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective is
none of your business bone
don't ever speak to me like that again
[Music]
why did you do that dude his pen up now
he knows problem solved
[Music]
excuse me
and i'm also sorry that a lot of people
here
for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny in fact it's pretty freaking
unfunny
oh great
[Music]
you're the luckiest son of a love yes it
was you got lucky at every turn no
i knew exactly where i was driving i
left my phone in the office on purpose i
was in a surgical suite by design and i
didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see was missing
i made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it then melted
it back down
it's already in a patient's mouth son
oh damn oh damn oh
damn and that is 3-0 dams
oh damn i'm prison mike
you know why they call me prison mike do
you really expect us to believe you're
somebody else do you really
expect me to not push you up against the
wall [ __ ]
all right hey hey hey that's just the
way we talk in the clink
but a lot of fun talk about prison today
but i am here to scare you straight
i am man as gay as died
in prison you are somebody's [ __ ]
oh and you you my friend would be
the bell of the ball don't drop the soap
don't drop the soap michael please
what's the very very worst thing about
prison don't encourage him dwight
the worst thing about prison was that
was the dementors they
were flying all over the place and they
were scary and then they come down and
they suck the soul out of your body and
it hurts
dementors like in harry potter no not
harry potter
tommy t you just missed the craziest of
crazies
clubs girls dancing naked mom
argument police fleeing the seat hiding
in a dumpster coming here
crashing on your couch for a week cause
technically i'm homeless
hey mustache i'ma hit the couch you know
i'll be
he's leaving our plan worked we saved
our own honeymoon and fun bonus we
cheered up holt yes
okay it's time to celebrate you know
what that means this bee needs a c
in her a oh my god this babe needs a
coconut in her arms oh
i thought you were saying this music oh
my god yeah that was my reaction all
right i'll go get us a couple of
coconuts
today smoking is gonna save lives
oh my god uh oh my god
oh my god okay it's happening everybody
stay calm what's the procedure
everyone what's the procedure have you
ever seen a burn victim
okay i am not dying here the fire's
shooting at us
there is no fire it was only a
simulation what
oh come on it's not real stanley don't
have a heart
no no no no no you will not die stanley
barack is president
you are black sadly i'm fine
you're saving me how could you possibly
think this is a good idea
what's going on here poppy mommy is here
can we keep him
my neighbor's dog had a literally
looking for people to adopt i love him
i wish he had tiny puppy shoes i would
totally shine his little shoes for free
oh i do say the cutest stuff look i love
a good dog as much as the next guy but
this building doesn't allow
animals andy take him outside and shoot
him
no just keep him outside oh
come on ron i'm just a little puppy
i ain't done nothing wrong i'm just a
puppy
i like your mustache i wish i could have
one
but i can't cause i'm just a little
puppy
okay take him out and shoot him number
one could you please sing the opening to
i want it that way
really okay
you are my fire
number two keep it going the one desire
number three believe when
i say number four i
wanted that away
tell me why ain't nothing but a heart
say
ah chills literal chills it was number
five
number five killed my brother oh my god
i forgot about that part what is your
name sir
i am bill butlicker really that's your
real name
how dare you my family built this
country by the way
be respectful dwight please oh yes
michael can you hold on one second
that's my other line
what no but i hello yeah
no i'm just on the phone with this
stupid salesman he's so dumb
probably just gonna keep him on the line
forever and not buy anything
okay it's up to you to change his mind
sorry that was a
family emergency oh no what's wrong you
know what that's private
boundaries dwight come on i'm sorry mr
buttlicker as i was saying
we're having a limited a little bit
louder i'm hard of hearing he's hard if
he's an old man
okay as i was saying right now we are
talking louder okay
our prices have never been low you have
to talk
that is totally inappropriate leslie go
home no i can't i can't go home i have
to get ready for the chamber of secrets
commerce if this meeting does not go
perfectly then the harvest festival is
gonna be over before it began i cannot
go home
okay then who is your doctor ann's my
doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world come on
oh girl no i'm hot now it's really hot
okay well that's your fever
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
[Music]
[Music]
you can't do that in person it's charles
boyle your co-worker
i feel like i'm the paris of people
[Music]
captain holt's not gay cam old's gay
seriously men just retire
[Music]
oh great i'll take my shirt off no one
asked you to take your shirt off
stop volunteering to take your shirt off
i can't hear you shirt's over my ears
as a manager of business you got a lot
of pride
but you also got a lot of responsibility
what do you think i think you're right
definitely looks suspicious
okay i'll call the police oh god that is
not mine
that is the stupidest thing you could do
right now if they find out you snitched
you get a dead horse's chopped off head
in your bed
it just seems awfully mean
but sometimes the ends justify the mean
you know a lot of these people this is
the only family they have
it's not a family it's a workplace why
don't you
go ahead and go die what can't you tell
me
a few weeks anyway what i declare
bankruptcy
[Music]
somebody shot me in the head
excuse me who even are you
how did you do this it's too late for me
i've seen too much but maybe i can save
them
it's your fault i'll just destroy this
office the people seem to be scared off
on account of it being hauled it
i no longer like ron
i'm gonna go finish him off we're not
against you on this
you're all gonna die in here i knew she
was a monster
tell me what to do leslie i wanna help
you take him down
you